welcome
and thank you for attending pharma
collaboration to advance
microfluidical systems a presentation
from the iqmps affiliate my name is
stephan baran
i'm a head of emerging technologies
within comparative medicine
at novartis institutes for biomedical
research
however today i'm presenting as a vice
chair
of the iq mps affiliate i would also
like to
thank the conference organizers from the
laboratory animal sciences labyrinth
conference
for establishing this track
addressing mps and also giving us an
opportunity
to present an iqmps affiliate
perspective
before we jump into different aspects of
mps
it is imperative for us to align or at
least to be on the same page
what do we define or what do we mean by
mps
so the iqmps affiliate defines mps as
going beyond
traditional 2d culture models where we
include
several of the following design aspects
multicellular environment within
bipolymer
or tissue derived matrix a 3d structure
an inclusion of mechanical cues such as
stretch or perfusion
for breathing gut paralysis flow
and incorporating primary or stem cell
derived cells
and or inclusion of immune system
components
below you see an image that visualizes
helps us visualize the definition which
was adapted from dash
and proctor so this is a pretty broad
definition
as you will see as we move to the
presentation depending on the context of
use
this definition can be refined but this
is
what we define as mps
by iqmps affiliate
so as we or many of us know
the microphysical systems have a high
transformational potential the first
context of use
commonly explored with these
technologies includes predictive and
mechanistic safety
more recently we have been looking from
efficacy
and disease modeling focus with broad
applications
and entry points the level of
qualification that's required for
implementation
is really dependent on the area where
mps is employed
depending on the context of use which
you will hear
me describe that today or talk about
that today
but also most people who presentations
you were here will address that as well
and of course pulling all of that
together these technologies have
enormous potential
to reduce refine and
hopefully in the future replace the use
of animals
in biomedical research
so where do these technologies fit in
and really we need to think from their
perspective or what are
challenges what are a problem so for
example where don't we have
in vivo models or good and viva models
so the exciting part about mps is they
really
they can fit into
any stage of the drug discovery and
development
journey so in target discovery
we can look at also target safety
assessments target validation
for early discovery you help us optimize
our leads and then even moving into
the early clinical development so
addressing or helping us mitigate
some of the issues that come up there so
the point of this figure is really
that depending on the context of use
this technology can potentially fit in
and help us address some of the
challenges
that we are facing so how do we engage
what's the best way to do that with mps
technologies so as we know again
there's a high potential for these
technologies to be smart transformative
and with any novel or emerging
technologies
this time to show the impact of these
technologies can be very
can be prolonged or very long so what's
the best way to
kind of engage at a faster pace
versus the traditional or the current
approach
so as a affiliate we have come together
and identify
the various areas which would allow us
to expedite
this path so one partnership or
collaboration
this is imperative so working
with all of the stakeholders industry
academics government
regulators and any other stakeholder
that's involved
in these technologies so looking at the
performance and capability development
what's really needed they're defining
the context of use
right where we're going to use these
technologies where it's going to fit for
us
is a mechanistic essay safety screening
dnpk
disposition efficacy and then of course
characterization so what is the cell or
tissue composition of these
technologies what's the physiological
function so having an understanding
there is going to help us as well
and then looking at validation
throughput capability intra
interlaboratory
reproducibility the stability of these
platforms
and what is the effectiveness and there
can be different definition of
characterization versus validation there
certainly can be some overlap there and
then
the fifth aspect is commercialization so
what is the data that we would need as
end users to engage and incorporate
these into our
daily processes and the data that would
help us
with our decision making process or
provide
actionable insight and this is pulling
all of this together
right i think in some times
the technology providers believe that
hey we're there this technology should
be utilized everybody should be using it
and as an end user well maybe we're not
there yet
we still need this this or that so
really pulling this information together
and bridging that gap
between the technology providers and the
end users
working collaboratively we can certainly
help engage and expedite engagement with
these technologies
where everybody benefits
so how did iqmps affiliate come about
so in first let me
describe the iq so iq which is
international consortium
for innovation and quality and
pharmaceutical development
and the iq which is formed by i believe
38 or so pharmaceutical companies
has leadership groups which you can see
listed on the left hand side
each leadership group also has working
groups
or specific working streams that address
specific topics
so in 2014 within the three rs
leadership group an mps working group
was established
and involved 11 companies and one of the
reasons for establishing this is that
the national center
for advancing traditional sciences or
ncats
wanted to learn where does our industry
see these technologies
so in 2015 we signed an mou
with ncats in 2016 the group
actually presented at ncats tissue chip
workshops
and 3d tissue model summit in 2017
the group published a position paper
which i just showed a couple slides
before
on these technologies how to navigate
chips from development to dissemination
to
end user utilization we also have
developed poster presentation
on five sets of organotypic standards uh
which served later on
for ben as a basis for our manuscripts
and in 2017 we also hosted a
face-to-face
workshop on industrialization
strategy so we really wanted to figure
out where should we go
what are our objectives what are our
goals so we got into a room
in dc and actually at that stage
we were still again not sure exactly
what we wanted to do
everybody had different ideas so within
you know i think
seven or eight hours were able to do
that and what we recognized that
being a working group wasn't enough for
us our aspirations were really high
there was a lot of projects that and
objectives we would like to reach
so we that's where we decided to
establish a microphysiological
affiliate
so currently this affiliate is made up
of 21
companies as you can see listed here the
representation is
very diverse from drug pharmacology
safety 3rs
admin pk pd and that has suddenly
evolved
the meeting that i mentioned
face-to-face meeting in 2017
i think out of that 12 or 13 or 14
people in a room
i was the only non-toxicologist person
in that room
so obviously you can see that the
representation has
diverse since then so our current
leadership
our fearless leader is jason eckert from
gsk
i have the honor of being the vice chair
vice elect is rihanna hardwick from
theravent
an immediate pest chair is terry van
vliet and a pest chair is william
proctor
from genentech so
iq mps affiliate has really four
aims overarching aims
one is for us to serve as a thought
leader for these technologies for
developers
and stakeholder organizations
also provide a venue for appropriate
cross-pharma collaboration
and this is where also data sharing
aspect comes into play
and i'll talk about that in a little bit
and what's the best way for us to do
that
and also engage with the regulators
so when emerging technologies innovative
technologies come about
very often we work with them
we collect data with those technologies
and then when we think already
this is when we engaged with the
regulators
and obviously they can prolong that
process
of engaging or deciding where to
implement those technologies
so here we wanted to engage with
regulators at the early stages
so from the beginning we can
work collaboratively and help evolve
these technologies in this field
we also have external partnerships and
collaboration
goal and as we know in this field
there's a lot of other organizations
conservation or groups that are engaged
with these technologies
and we want to make sure that we don't
duplicate efforts that are happening
somewhere else
or identify opportunities we can
collaborate
to actually help move this field forward
so our current work streams we have five
of them
one is organic manuscripts then we also
have
project proposal teams we have a gaap
survey
team regulatory outreach
work stream and the external
organization
outreach work stream and i'll talk about
each one of these in more detail
so the landscape and gap assessment
survey team
their the goal for this team was to
really understand how pharmaceutical
companies are
engaging with these technologies how are
we using these technologies
um and you know when we think about
these complex in vitro models and what
are some of the challenges
you know why aren't we engaging with
them um in in
and how can we realize full potential
of mps so in 2019 we conducted a survey
and then in 2020
we actually redesigned the survey also
working with fda and incorporating fda
feedback to the survey 2.0
this survey was launched at the end of
last year and we have collected the
responses
from it in early january and now we're
processing and analyzing the data
and the objective for this group is also
pull
the results from both of the surveys and
develop a commentary manuscript
where we're also going to address
longitudinal analyses
of both of these surveys and the results
from these surveys
so for our first survey the definition
that we used
for um complex in vitro models or nps is
pretty broad
so this is you know the definition that
i gave a few slides earlier so i'm not
going to really go into that
and we really wanted to have it broad so
we could
engage as many stakeholders as we could
they have been working with these
technologies or even just interested in
with these technologies
our 2.0 survey we have refined or
refocused the definition
and you can see that on the image there
at the bottom of the slide
so our initial survey included all five
of these aspects
and for our 2.0 survey
we end up including that
last two aspects so here we define
in vitro systems that could include 3d
bioprinted tissues
microfluidic systems or combinations
thereof
with fluid or airflow
coupled with cells and these could be
primary cell
cell lines and stem cells and they need
to recapitulate components
of organ physiology and
in this survey mps
does not include static organoids
spheroids or micro pattern conculture
systems
so i'm going to go through some of the
questions
that were presented within survey 1.0
and the answers to those questions
so first wanted to find out you know who
responded to the survey
was the makeup of the folks that
participated in there
so 28 respondents get 23
members of the iqmps affiliate that
participated
we actually had five additional
companies they were not members of the
iqmps affiliate
but did participate in a survey
the survey was 97 questions right so
it's not one of those five
six question surveys it was pretty
intense it took significant amount of
time and effort to complete
so if you think about the number of
respondents that we actually received
was
really high it just demonstrates
the interest and then engagement of
these pharmaceutical companies
in these technologies
so then we subdivided
respondents into small mid-size and
large so for small
less than a thousand employees mid-size
thousand to ten thousand and large
over ten thousand and as you can see
majority of the respondents were large
companies
so 18 of them and then for mid size we
had eight
and for small size we had two companies
so the question also was you know so
have you engaged with
these technology so 26 companies said
yes
and two companies said no that said
though
even though they said no they are still
interested
in working with these technologies
potentially
so the reason for not engaging with them
was lack of resources
but also that the key decision makers
wanted to see where this technology
wanted to
engage with the technology after already
matures a little bit more
so what's the rationale and advantages
of engaging or using
these technologies so the major
two were lack of current tools or
systems
and improve current models ability to
replicate human
and or animal physiology and third
improve current essay capabilities was
right
there as well and then other which
included
three r's motivation mechanisms
translational toxicology and human
biology
so what are some of the observations
that these organizations have made they
were advantageous with engagement
so the largest percentage
was 22 companies you know replicate
physiology more accurately
then we had more sensitive systems
they capture more endpoints capture more
time
points and then other also included you
know longer duration
of the of the system of the cells being
alive live imaging
where it's not possible for example with
in vivo models
so how do you resource uh these
technologies
so this kind of was a pretty even split
right so
almost 90 percent resourced it in house
a little bit over 80 percent was through
external collaboration
and then 80 almost 80 was fee for
service
and then there was a smaller percentage
which were other
for example academic collaborations
so where does each company source these
models from
so the highest number was from
vendors so commercial products and it
makes sense right it's easier to engage
with those technologies
um you can just jump in you know bring
it in potentially use it or use it
uh as a fee for service then we had
academia
which again these are early stages um
this field is in early
stages so it makes sense to engage with
academic groups that are evolving
developing these technologies
then we also had vendors and internal as
well so some companies are
developing these systems internally
so how internally we
are addressing resources for these
technologies
so how many people are part of
engagement
or internal efforts with
these systems so
40 percent or almost 40 percent had
between
anywhere between 11 to 50 people
and then we had 5 to 10 and then
over 50 percent i'm sorry over
only a couple companies had over 50
associates
engaged with these technologies and for
us
obviously for all of these questions but
specifically this one
will be interesting to see how that
progresses from survey 1.0
to survey 2.0 especially when we
refocused
the definition of mps
so then you know what divisions where
departments
are actually working with these
technologies um so again
there was a three almost like a three
even split say a dmpk
research biology preclinical safety
safety assessment we also had biomarker
discovery
and some other areas like disease areas
discovery therapy
therapy early clinical development
and one of the points to take home from
here is
the initial slide that i show that that
these technologies can really fit in
almost anywhere
from early discovery uh to later
development
of our medicines
one of the questions was also you know
are decentralized efforts
right or not already segmented and as we
know some things can be challenging when
things are siloed
so we really wanted to gauge that as
well
and only small percentage of companies
responded only to that those efforts
were centralized
not surprisingly within most companies
these efforts were
segmented there was a few companies that
actually had
other ways they had a core or a mix of
both
of various working groups
so of course it's always interesting
right or good to learn
where our decision makers or key
decision makers
um are in
you know where are they thinking what
are they thinking about these
technologies you know could this have
really big impact or not
so really high percentage over 50
percent believe that technology has
value and great potential and already
are
investing and are planning to invest in
continuing engagement with these
technologies
about 30 percent said there's unproven
to date so there's more information
needed for
regarding these technologies to
demonstrate the value
but our investing in these technologies
and willing to explore uh the potential
of these technologies and there are
obviously some other reasons
you know like for example is there a
trust in that technology
but you know it's hard to manage the
approval process
but no one really said that these
technologies are not proven
and unlikely to me its potential which
is
really exciting to see that
everybody that participate in the survey
sees some kind of potential and
advantages
to working with these technologies
of course understanding which system
is of the highest priority uh is
important
obviously to us as an industry but also
for the technology providers right so
where they can concentrate their efforts
to engage with these technologies or
develop these technologies
so not surprisingly liver
is is one of them again even just
thinking back
right when i said the first meeting that
we had you know there's mainly
toxicologists
present in a room but obviously that has
evolved right so they're looking at gi
kidney cns and immune system
so where are these technologies used
right so i
reference the context of use which is
really imperative when we talk about
these technologies
so on the left hand side on the top you
can see some of the types
of these technologies and so here we
have a chart
right so in which area these
technologies that
use in the kind of percentage
right so for safety static 3d
technologies are are pretty common you
also have a 2d micro pattern technology
as well when you look at the admin
again they're through 2d micro pattern
technologies
and therefore pharmacology is kind of
evenly
split but the static 3d technology suits
again
not surprisingly and so those are the
most frequently used
models and one of the things for the
second survey
where we again are focusing more on the
more complex
nps we're really curious to see
if some of this data
is going to change and we really are
expecting that it would change
but only the analysis of the survey
results
will will tell us but even here
you can see that engagement with the
organonic chip technologies
or the more complex systems there is
still some engagement and uh you're
looking at the mechanism
looking at the species differentiation
as well as screening
in all three of these areas safety admin
and pharmacology
but overwhelmingly at least for this
first survey
the most frequently used models where
the 2d micro patterned
and static 3d models
so at what stage of drug discovery and
development journey
are we're engaging with these
technologies so preclinical safety
most commonly then looking at lead
optimization
and then it's kind of evenly split for
target id
and validation and lead identification
and then obviously we do have some
engagement also in the clinical
development
and in other areas like pkpd looking at
the mechanistic
aspect and drug to drug interactions
so what modalities are we testing
with these technologies so here
overwhelmingly small molecules
but biotherapeutics are right behind
we're also engaging with cell and gene
therapy and you know i'd be curious to
see
actually with this new survey if there
has increased because this is certainly
an area where we don't have a lot of
in vivo models where we can test
safety and efficacy of these therapies
and to a smaller percentage
of engagement is in vaccines and
and other therapies
i'd also like to point out that
commercial and active proprietary
compounds
and terminated property compounds are
equally used when evaluating
these technologies
so of course a question that many of us
are certainly interested in
you know has the data from these systems
been part of regulatory submission or
where else are we utilizing
uh this data to make decisions
um so we are certainly
looking at using this data to qualify
models
it's certainly utilized internally for
decision making
which makes sense again especially with
emerging technologies
but um 18
of the participants for the survey said
that they have utilized this data for
regulatory submission
and there are some other areas about 30
or so
you know when you're looking at weighing
of the evidence
looking at the mechanistic aspects
and also our planning and that currently
did not but are planning to include this
data in regulatory submissions
so 25 percent they have submitted data
to the regulatory agencies which is 7
out of the 28 companies
stated that the data incorporated
into non-clinical toxicology human
pharmacokinetics
and bioavailability and non-clinical
pharmacology sections
of the regulatory filings and
the data was also submitted globally
so to fda emea and pdma
and 64 they have not submitted
this data to regulatory agencies you
know so why is that
so they didn't have confidence in the
data there were also concerns
regarding regulatory acceptance of
the data and that submission
the models are not currently fully
characterized
and also lack of confidence from
internal
stakeholders and you saw some of the
answers from
the key stakeholders or decision makers
that some of them have thought that
these technologies have not evolved yet
or matured enough to potentially
submit into these regulatory agents
so to summarize the outcome of the
survey
is that which is i think pretty exciting
that these models are equally being
applied in safety admin pharmacology
the resources are segmented across
groups
which you know personally i hope that's
going to evolve
and we're going to see that in a second
survey the sources
of these technologies are mainly from
vendors followed by
academic but also some internal
development as well the human and
preclinical model species
are equally being evaluated
there is some but limited interest in
multi-organ
integrated systems and i think there
again we really need to
characterize and qualify these
individual systems before there is
excitement
regarding the multi-organ integrated
systems
for utilization of these technologies
currently they really are mainly used
for internal decision making processes
nine companies that use these
technologies i use it for clinical
development
but five companies also use them uh for
data for regulatory submissions
so uh there's definitely uh progression
and evolution
where this data is being utilized we
look at you know what modalities
um so currently predominantly small
molecule
and some biotherapeutics and
there's definitely need for additional
characterization
an interior internal experiences
with these models in order to increase
the uptake and application
of these technologies these are
definitely not you know like a pcr kit
you can just grab from the shelf read
instructions and utilize
um so i'm having experiences with these
technologies setting them up
in addition to the other aspects that
we know we kind of brought up or i've
discussed and presented
you will certainly see addressed in
other presentations
but we're get we're getting there
so now i'll switch gears a little bit
and talk about
inorganic manuscripts working stream so
the goal for this team is really to
summarize challenges and gaps in current
in vitro and in vivo models and
you know what information would be
meaningful to us
from these systems
to demonstrate the capabilities
and what is that improvement over our
current standard models and we also
describe in these manuscripts
you know endpoints that are of interest
to us you know what are some of the
readouts that we would like to see
and what compounds should be tested
right so i mentioned earlier that
um you know very often the technology
providers
evolve develop these technologies
and we're not always jumping in um you
know and
engaging with them so the idea behind
these manuscripts is actually to
provide some guidance on what we would
expect from these technologies
before we engage or even
you know while we're engaging to
increase that engagement
and the impact of these technologies so
the deliverables
for this group are pretty amazing i mean
to be honest in
since 2019 we have published nine
manuscripts
and just to think about you have you
know 21 pharmaceutical companies coming
together
and um agreeing on you know even what
endpoints to use
can be very very challenging right so to
come together
and really within last i would say less
than a year or so
to publish these manuscripts to me it
was just an amazing
uh deliverable and we're also now
looking at publishing or working on
additional manuscripts um so
as i already mentioned you know that
these manuscripts kind of evolved from
the posters
they were presented
at the ncats tissue chip consortium
meetings
um and they really address the three
questions
that i kind of already mentioned right
the challenges and gaps and current in
vitro and in vivo models
and it's imperative to do that to point
those out
so then we can actually see what are
some of the advantages
and the meaningful improvements that
these technologies would have
over the other ones um and also you know
the endpoints
online readouts um test compounds to
share those
with the technology developers um so
on the right hand side you see
manuscripts that are published
and on the left hand side you see the
manuscripts that we're currently
drafting
if you like to see these manuscripts
they have been published they're open
access you can go to
the link that's listed there iqnps.org
and just click on a tab for publications
so here's the list of these publications
they were all published and
lab on a chip we have an introductory
manuscript which
where we dive into a little bit more in
depth you know why we are publishing
this series
and the potential impact of these
technologies
and then you have you know the other
systems organs
addressing here you know from lung all
the way to
cardiovascular but again you can
access these manuscripts at their open
access
on the website iqmps.org
so the next work stream that i would
like to talk about as a regulatory
engagement team
and i could go on and on about this work
stream
and i'm slightly biased since i have the
honor of
chairing this group but really the goal
for us here
moving forward is to continue our
engagement with
fda we're also
drafting a manuscript from our workshop
which happened in early 2020
and we're also planning on having a
workshop this year later in the fall
hopefully face-to-face but if not
virtual with with fda
and we also have established a strategy
on engaging with
regulators outside of united states um
and we believe again as i mentioned
before right that engaging with
regulators at these earlier stages
um is is imperative uh to advance this
field
um of with these technologies and
we have received an awesome response uh
for from fda
the interaction has been incredible
there
um and back and forth discussions and we
continue to have
frequent teleconferences between these
engagement
so we really believe that again
this collaborative interaction will help
us
understand these technologies and move
these technologies and advance them
so what are our deliverables so so far
as i mentioned in february 2020
we had a joint workshop with
fda and iqmps affiliate and this was at
fda location we also
agreed to develop the post workshop
publication
where we will discuss the outcomes or
what happened
at the workshop and our perspective on
these technologies
and we also worked with fda to provide
us with
questions which we could incorporate
into
the survey 2.0 so they had a chance to
look at that we actually presented some
of the survey results at this workshop
that we had with fda
and now having incorporated some of the
questions
that were shared with us through fda um
it just
gonna really help us better understand
um what they are looking for
um in this survey and then we also have
initiated
webinar series um so between these
workshops the face-to-face workshops we
really want to continue our engagement
so we had so far two webinars where you
have representatives from
iqmps affiliate nfda and addressing
various topics
and presentations but we do spend quite
a bit of time
with q a and discussions
which have been very productive
so as i mentioned you know we have a
communication and external organization
outreach uh group um and
it's imperative for us to to to have
this group
because one to communicate all of the
things that we're doing
and having a comprehensive communication
strategy
even just within the iq but obviously
also
externally and you know how to engage
with non-regulatory stakeholders
right so as the field is expanding and
growing there's a lot of other
organizations that are engaging or
working in this area so again
we don't want to duplicate efforts so
this group is looking
at other stakeholders and engaging with
them
to see you know can we collaborate
together or
share information so some of the
deliverables
this group has launched an awesome
website iqmpsaffiliate.org again that's
where you can find information about
us but also different projects that
we're working on
and also having access to the
publications that i mentioned earlier
this group has also implemented a social
media strategy
so for example you can see us on
linkedin um and you can join us there
and see updates from this group one of
the
things that you know as a camp is
affiliate very often we're asked to
participate and present at different
events conferences or workshops so
each time we had to develop you know
powerpoint slides or presentations for
each one of those
so this was pretty intense process so
this group helped us develop
a presentation materials which we can
utilize to communicate
our accomplishments and our efforts and
obviously
that result from that is what you're
seeing even today
that i'm presenting and we also want to
raise awareness
with the key external stakeholders
regarding us as an iqmp as affiliate
um but even more importantly about these
technologies
and where pharmaceutical industry sees
these technologies
moving forward
so our project proposals team is also
very busy and certainly
very excited excited team
so there's three areas here where this
project team is working on
so one looking at ability to share
data retrospective data so
various members of iqmbps affiliate
and obviously i have been working with
these technologies
so it's an opportunity for us in a
pre-competitive environment to share
the data um right and where to share it
and how to do it
who would have access to it as you can
imagine that's not an easy proposition
but we are certainly working on it um
and the goal
for this specific project is to develop
a mechanism in a framework
to share collate and analyze existing
nps data the milestones here
we have initiated a call for
participants to join
this discussion and we are focusing on
specific organs or context of use
the other objective here
is for joint characterization right so
identify
a specific organ and be able to
characterize it
so here we have actually made quite a
bit of progress i shouldn't say actually
we are making quite a bit of progress
the first area of interest was a gi
mps and then second kidney mps and you
can actually go
on our website and see an rfi
and rfp for the gi
mps which enable
prospective and collaborative projects
to characterize
these two platforms the gi and and the
kidney one
the kidney one uh we also have engaged
with psdc
kidney biomarkers team and again this
came through that
other working group the collaborative
collaborative
group that i mentioned before the
suggestion from there were engaged
with the pstc and that we identified
this is one
area where we could collaborate so again
so we're not duplicating efforts
and then the third project
is a category is prospective
collaborations
so here the goal is to identify
collaboration and alignment
opportunities
for ongoing projects within our
individual companies
so we have initiated a call for
participants
to join these groups and discussions
and we're going to be focusing on
specific organs and context of use
we have not defined those which wasn't
prioritized as yet
but we're getting there
so the other big question really comes
up
when we think about these technologies
is which species
so should we engage with human
cell-based mps or animal cell based mps
and a lot of efforts until now
have really concentrated on a human cell
based mps
and of course you know when you think
about it it does make sense
right we're trying to uh translate
our medicines from pre-clinical
to clinics we want to make sure that
those medicines are safe
and effective for our patients we're
trying to do it
at a faster pace if at all possible so
working with
human cell based mps for human medicines
makes sense but there's certainly some
areas where
the animal cell based mps can be helpful
and so here obviously i'm going to
address
in the context of drug discovery and
development
but there are also other areas there was
just a workshop
sponsored by national academy of
sciences where animal cell based
technologies were discussed in the
context of for example veterinary
medicine
or agro chemical industry
so there are certainly other areas where
these technologies are also
playing a significant role but so let's
step back
and talk about you know these two
aspects within drug discovery and
development
so we have come together and have
developed
a position statement on
utilization of animal cell based
microphysical systems
and here i'll just mention them as
animal mps
so we certainly are recognizing the
importance and the impact
and the need for animal models we
certainly would not be able to
provide all of the medicines that we're
currently are providing to
our patients without in vivo models
but there are certainly some areas where
we can refine where there's for example
lack of those models or the models
are not as helpful as they potentially
could be
so we are recognizing you know there's a
new approach
new methodologies that we couldn't that
could enhance
this drug discovery and development path
so exclusive utilization of human
cell-based systems
if we that's the direction we're going
to go and it makes it really challenging
to support the investigation of
species-specific mechanisms
demonstrate the models recapitulate his
topological findings where we have
significant amount of data
from our pre-clinical in vivo studies
and validate predictivity for toxicities
that only occur above relevant clinical
exposures in humans
right so there's only up to a certain
expo
a certain level that we can expose
folks they're part of clinical trials so
if we want to go beyond that
obviously we're not able to do that so
animal mps systems
could help us in this specific area
so this is where again we're suggesting
that
mps composed of cells from other species
can help us advance microphysiological
systems
and their use
so with that
with supporting utilization of animal
cell-based systems you know where else
can they help us
right so for example cross-referencing
animal cell-based mps data
with enormous amount of in-vivo animal
data that we already have
to accelerate the development and
validation of novel mps technologies
right there's not we have human
cell data but not certainly to the
extent that we have in vivo
the amount that we have in of in vivo
animal data
we can also leverage animal and vivo
data with animal mps data to gain
confidence
and productivity of human
microphysiological systems
and also identifying species-specific
differences
for selection of translating models
through mps species comparison
and especially for the rare diseases
developing transgenic and
disease-specific mps models
with cells derived from transgenic mice
and rats as we know the transgenic
in vivo models have been enormously
helpful
and evolving and developing various
medicines for our patients
so here utilizing the cells
transgenic or modified genetically
modified cells
can be very helpful a carrying out
structure activity relationship
or sar and mechanistic studies in
instances
where there are non-clinical toxicology
issues they need resolution so for
example
nephrotoxicity or central nervous system
taxes
toxicity and then also comparing
admin in non-clinical species and human
so iqb's affiliate supports the three
r's
the refinement reduction and replacement
i know many of you are aware of
this concept but for those are not those
are the concepts that were described
in the 1959 by russo and burch
in the principles of humane experimental
technique
and the current use of mps technologies
has already direct
impact on refinement and reduction
in drug discovery and development with
the long-term goal of animal replacement
in the future
we're certainly not there yet and it's
going to take some time
but that's the potential that these
technologies have
so again i want to acknowledge
right that here i'm just representing um
iq mps affiliate i'm giving a
presentation on behalf
of that consortia that that affiliate
and this presentation involved a lot of
different folks uh pulling it together
i certainly would like to thank
secretariat so jillian brady catherine
gravlin
reid abrahamson and mary devlin capezzi
and all of the iqmbps affiliate
participating companies
which i can't spend the next couple of
hours naming everybody there
uh but again everybody that has
contributed to all of the efforts
um and evolution of this
presentation if you have any questions
you can also reach me at the linkedin
link that you have there on the bottom
but you can also reach out to our
secretariat colleagues which are listed
there
mary and jillian so thank you so much
for attending this session i hope you
find it useful
and i'm looking forward to engaging with
you on questions and answers and a
discussion
and even hopefully offline thank you so
much